hey what's up welcome back to another
episode of animators react we are joined
by the one and only Tom bftt here today
we're going to be looking at a bunch of
cool stuff Tom what are we looking at
though well we're going to go back and
we're going to learn about the old
school today and how it's affect the new
school I like
school
weird another childhood favorite of mine
what is this Nostalgia Lane we're going
to look at old school Disney stuff and
how that now translates into what's
happening now in computer
animation you got to say I love you back
even this this isn't super easy to do in
2D an action sequence much easier to
pull off they're bringing a lot of what
feels like traditional animation
techniques into modern animation it'll
be interesting to get this Insight from
you and where this is coming from why
it's there how it's been used and maybe
even some places where it doesn't work
all right let's do this let's jump
[Music]
in
so this is the Old Mill
1937 that was a few years ago yeah it
dates us doesn't it I was born 1938 just
after this and but anyway but really
what's groundbreaking in this film is
it's the first use of the multiplane
camera I was wondering I saw that
Parallax going by that little leaf that
was moving faster than the
[Music]
background there it is right there so
there's some right there you've heard
about Parallax and things like that
obviously this is still a term that we
use today in film this film LED to Snow
White without this film there would have
been no snow white wow okay now is
something like this a multiplane moment
as well it's a good question so though
this wouldn't be considered a multiplane
shot they were so expensive and timec
consuming to create that they were very
sporadic like they go okay you get five
multiplane shots and they tended to be
establishing shots where you're like
coming into a setting like at the
beginning of of the film or something
like that and I've done this before to
Cal Arts we had the old Platinum that
Disney had donated to Cal arts and it
was from Dumbo was the rumor that Dumbo
was shot on it there'd be a peg strip
down here you'd put on all your cells
the background first of course and then
the cameras up there shooting down and
it's just this big glass thing with
hinges and you'd shut it down and then
you put click do that one frame Do It
All Over Again these cameramen would
just stay up all night and shoot
everything that was finished that day oh
that that'd be so easy to mess up that'
be so easy to mess up oh it gets messed
up yeah now usually they catch it in
dailies by the way dailies were weeklys
they weren't dieses but in Bambi there's
a shot where a raccoon
disappears they knew when they released
Bambi that this was a mistake but this
was such a hard shot because of this
camera move and everything watch that
raccoon oh there it goes oh wow so it's
in the movie and it's been in the movie
for what 40 50 years now I don't know
how long it's been out but but how would
that happen the pop thing and I can tell
you why we have pegs right and so you
can have an apeg A bpeg and A cpeg so
that some characters are on the apeg
that are taking place all in that area
cuz the cells are only so wide they're
not this wide they're this wide the
cameraman put it on the wrong Peg oh
kept going and he probably realized it
when he did it and he just kept going
cuz he's like I've been shooting this
for8 hours I'm not going to go back and
fix that well probably won't even
notice but I guarantee they noticed it
probably within a week and they went
sorry because literally back in that day
think about it and it's kind of fun you
got like you guys have made a job out of
it right finding those things so what
would you guys do without that I know
there you go filmmakers are lazy
sometimes what can you
say ho ho Santa here brought to you by
today's sponsor Bessie now I know you're
probably worried because you still have
gifts to buy bess's make the best
holiday gifts and to prove it I'm going
to be going around the studio and giving
everyone a little vessie surprise H ho
ho I've heard you've been a good boy
you've made some really good videos this
year bess's our versatile shoe that you
can wear in rain sleet or snow but on
top of that they also come in many
different styles and colors to choose
from so you'll be sure to find something
for everyone on your nice list Bessie
also offers clothes and accessories that
you can wear that are also of course
waterproof I'm going to give you this
hat a hat it's waterproof wouldn't you
believe it I wouldn't
oh it's a good boy good boy I feel like
a child again yes he vessie vessie are
the perfect shoe for winter because they
are you guessed it completely
[Music]
waterproof merry kmas Merry Christmas
have you been a good boy I have okay
these are some of the best kicks you'll
ever have by today's sponsor vessie Get
Down
Tonight get down tonight there's these
in many other styles if you just going
to vested
/cc what is going on why are you so
suspicious oh I'm not suspicious I'm
from the North Pole there good boy
they're made from a magical material
called diatex that keep your feet warm
in the winter and cool in the summer so
you can wear them all year round oh
great I just get one another one for you
you know the diamex material keeps you
very very warm but there's something
inside that will keep you warmer what
been a real good boy lots of good
simulations and Sims and there no are we
doing this oh no he got call cuz he's a
bad
boy well my time here is done but if you
or a loved one have Bessie on your
Christmas list head to bessie. comom
crew to get 15% off your first whole
order merry kristmas we left on rather
unusual
Footprints they obviously belong to the
same fiend who abducted the girl's
father The Great Mouse Detective love
this movie this was like a childhood
favorite of mine I love hearing that you
just dated me I was I was in college
when this came out I
think can you guys see it wait AE oh
there's like threedimensional
perspective changes oh there it is there
it is what is it wait is it actually 3D
is this traced over no so it is the
first computer animation hybrid at least
at Disney I I'm not a historian to that
degree but here's what they did to hide
it is they print printed out every
single frame onto cells like a big Xerox
machine the animator would then use the
digital printouts that they would Peg
and then would animate the character
over every single frame and paint it
like it was a cell so they were all hand
painted so it would integrate normally
like especially in modern day you can
kind of end up telling when it's a
computer generated cartoon because the
self shaded nature of the render you can
usually kind of tell there's a
difference between that and like an
actual like handdrawn painting but here
it does look the same the only thing
that kind of gives it away is it's like
the perspective shifting of everything
is very good it's perfect yeah yeah but
you get some of that creep like that
very first shot where basil wakes up on
that gear and you can see his feet are
sliding slightly that was the first time
that ever been done and and they they
were just applauding that animator for
like wait you did it it looks like he's
on that if you want to jump ahead
there's another spot where they did that
where now they've gotten really good at
it and that's the ballroom sequence and
Beauty and the Beast wait do you
remember that when you were young like
they now it's funny cuz like it didn't
stand out to me as CGI do I remember
seeing the movie and I remember that
scene as before but now can't you see it
like so obvious now here yeah isn't it
obvious like because they rendered it
now they didn't do what they did in
Great Mouse Detective where they printed
out the paper and actually put it on
cells this is an actual 3D rendering of
that background with handdrawn
characters over it but what's impressive
is how Talent this animator had to be to
get the perspective would there have
been any value in trying to actually
render out like a grid yeah and that
that would have been in the CG that he
had so basically again they printed out
every frame of the CG animation that was
done low poly and so he could animate to
every single frame but he still had to
draw it right and get the perspective
changed and then while they're moving in
circles but while they're looking at
each other and acting and I can't tell
you how hard it is to do it's Master
workor right here so shout out to James
Baxter this is one of the modern day
best animators in the world one of the
top 10 probably and he animated both
Bell and beast in this three or four
shots the opening shot of of Rescuers is
is pretty cool Rescuers Down Under resc
another childhood favorite of mine what
is this Nostalgia
[Music]
Lane so this is the first film I've ever
worked on this is my first credit in a
feature phone but now watch this so
they're doing Parallax they're doing
multiplane this shot was like amaz oh
yes I do remember this shot I do
remember this shot shot I love your
excitement I do no like this is like my
childhood is literally just flashing
before my eyes right now so now these
are CG now though this is multiplane but
digital but these are CG flowers and
this is a flat house that we're about to
head into and look how bad that looks oh
like they couldn't get into the window
they just we went into black and then
they cross dissolved like even that
stick like that goes out of focus that
stick should fly out the camera as we
move forwards but they they ease out of
it
right what time the title but like watch
how the title eases in with it so it
gives this feeling that we're like
starting to fly right right I remember
this was like very early in the film and
one of the last shots done at the same
time
I know I'm coming now this is the new
generation of animators too so Beauty
and the Beast and rescues down under are
really the two films that was where
people like me were coming in and we
were starting to mix in with the second
generation of animators that were
trained by the nine old men the ones
that were there from from Snow White
this is that transition where it's got
some really good animation and then some
not so great animation because we were
all still learning learning and stuff
when Glen King comes on this is what
you're talking about is the eagle
sequence dude this kid's just free
soloing this
Cliff I know Alex honold right
here you're
free this is like another level of
Animation to me you can see like just
the dimensionality and the drawing
ability and the consistency and just the
appeal really
wind the wind but like Cody just looks
cuter and things like that that's the
appeal side of it I know this is good
stuff I'm just like so distracted about
how epic this whole sequence is like
just like moment after moment just like
this is incredible so this is all Glenn
Kean he's just known to be the best
animator in the world and so he was the
supervising animator of Maro so most all
these Maro shots are him doing just what
he does which is just amazing drawing
amazing animation and that takes years
to do and some of us I must admit just
never get to that level and that's the
difference between back then a master 2D
animator and the rest of
us to be
honest all right let's do this one last
time these newer films that have been
coming out are starting to bring a lot
of these traditional animation elements
I'm curious you know with with your eye
what stands out to you and like what
kind of like elements techniques lineage
like things you could point out to us
that pops in these fils
so with CG animation and why it's taking
off maybe even well it has gone further
it killed 2D animation let's be honest
um but why it's so popular is that
obviously you can do so many things with
it and I mean the level of subtlety all
that stuff like what we looked at with
marut but with the human character like
even this this isn't super easy to do in
2D in action sequence much easier to
pull off because what's hard in 2D is
all those perspective changes of his
face and oh wait is that eye now
floating and moving around because
they're not fixed objects right eyes can
slide noses can slide and so in the
cleanup side of things it has to be Rock
Solid and feel like it is the but in CG
it is Rock Solid it's actually harder to
do the opposite where you contort the
character yeah they have animators there
that are being pushed to go no film
yourself and that's really popular
obviously in CG animation is to film
yourself by the way we couldn't do that
in the '90s
have iPhones and all those things let me
just pull out my pocket film camera
right right we like literally using
mirrors and like making faces and
mirrors this generation is going oh wait
we want these characters to be
believable and so therefore we have to
look at life but they're also then
throwing an appeal what do you think
you're going he got a bagel all right
time to swing just like I taught you
okay now let's talk about the one thing
that I don't agree with in spiderverse
I'm going to get in trouble all right
heck yeah um and it's timing so you've
heard over and over again we would put
things on twos like we'd literally tell
the computer take out every other frame
on Fast movements we were trained at
Disney to do that always on ones meaning
every drawing you put in for every frame
you don't put it on twos twos was used
more for when the characters do stop and
they just talk to each other and where
it's a little bit slower movement and
that was a cost savings thing but it
also ended up looking a little bit more
natural in the 2D World on action scenes
it should all just be on ones is my
opinion that'll give you that fluidity
where your eye can kind of keep up with
what's going on to me this gets too
jerky because they're applying twos or
whatever kind of throughout the whole
film a little bit more blanket than they
should there's times like that look like
it was W's where she screams by and
maybe because she's graceful Gwen maybe
they put her more on ones than on twos
like some of the other characters cuz
Peter Parker is on ones but miles is on
twos and I thought that was to signify
that he's still kind of like an amateur
Spider-Man he doesn't really know how to
be smooth yeah I don't know I haven't
seen that critique that you have but uh
when I saw it on the big screen there
were shots where a character would walk
across screen and it was very obvious
they put it on twos and I was like oh it
it bothered me cuz I was like that just
jerked across screen why are they doing
that and then I saw action sequences in
New York where they're jumping around
I'm like I can't keep up with what's
going on it was just a little too much
is all I'm saying now do I appreciate it
I still do I mean it's not broken we're
talking about artistic decisions which
by the way I love by the way that we're
talking about it but there's no real
rules you know I'm working on a film
right now and it's a 2d feature film but
we have to make decisions every day some
of them are budget related others are
just related to well is that going to
look weird and when you're doing it on
the drawing side where you're just
designing characters and then the
layouts and starting to see them in
pencil drawings you still don't know
what it's really going to look like
until it's all animated in color and so
there's still guesswork but I love these
movies I love
them so you're a producer of a a film
coming out called pencils versus pixels
right yeah it's my first liveaction
documentary I'm really proud of it so it
Chronicles the change this Evolution
that happened where we went from
traditional animation in the 9s to CG
animation yeah I mean I started at
Disney like we said before on Rescuers
Down Under and really that jump you
could say started a little bit with
Little Mermaid and then Beauty and the
Beast it was just growing and growing of
course once Lion King came out that's
when the floodgates opened it was our
first billion dooll film and all the
studios wanted to have 2D animation
units and creating 2D animated feature
films literally within a few years
computer animation came along it started
with Toy Story of course being the first
CG feature film and it just did so well
but really it was Shrek that closed the
door Shrek made so much money they went
oh they just want CG this doesn't even
look that great and everybody loves it
and they're pouring money into it okay
2D's gone go it's a story that I felt
need to be told we made this film and
we're very proud of it that it gets that
story out from the not the business
people but from the artists themselves
now I know you're a producer on this but
are you in this at all are you
interviewed yeah I'm in it there I am
that looks so
bald I guess it's true now I do have a
twin brother Tony he's in it also so
it's going to feel like I'm in there a
lot but I'm not actually that's not me
that's not me that was
T he's showing a little too much
chess but we have like legendary
animators we talked about Glenn Kean we
talked about James Baxter in this
episode Floyd Norman who's a a veteran
that's been around for years he actually
was at the studio when Walt was still Al
live you know Mna win is a friend of
mine she's the voice of Mulan and she
came in and did an amazing narration
throughout wait is this out yet can we
see this as of right now you can buy it
or rent it at Apple TV and all those uh
places Amazon hit the link and go get it
right now don't rent it buy it cuz
you're going to want to watch it
multiple times
okay thank boom man I like this school
session but if you're to come back what
can we talk about next time I don't know
but I'd love to hear in the comments
everybody let us know what we should
talk about next time this is great I
really enjoyed this I have so much fun
every time guys every time all right I'm
going to go watch The Rescuers Down
Under now and pencils versus pixels oh
that one too
yes episodes every weekend consider
subscribing